there's nothing you can do the black  king is just coming in  even if you cut it off even if you cut  off the king's advance then now the  black pawn is just going to step forward  and protect its body here and once this  pawn is protected the black rook is free  perfect technique he's going to win now  wow making a comeback in the match after  losing the first game how impressive by  the 16 year old the bar now saying seven  advantage and it looks like ding has  resigned  it's over and now heidi maybe it's  possible to read ding's body language  yeah oh yeah  he does not seem too happy right now and  pray that number you could see he had  like this  sigh it looked like he was he was very  happy about this yeah he has made a  comeback the 16 year old they are now  tied after two games dingley ren and  pragnanda both of them winning with the  black pieces and uh what a performance  prague in this game both of the players  still sitting by the computers looking  over this